The Joe Rogan Experience do you know the
wacky conspiracy theory and this is
wacky about uh the South Pole the South
Pole is some sort of a direct energy
weapon weapon that there's like some
station down there that they've
pretended is just for receiving but it's
actually for transmitting
I have no idea if any of this is
nonsense it's just fun it's fun when
people talk crazy but this guy was on
the Sean Ryan Show and uh he is a air
quotes whistleblower and he's explaining
how he went down there and he read the
operating manual for this device and
this device caused the earthquakes and
Christ Church New Zealand and I was like
what
like what is this it's so hard to know
if you're just a comic in Austin how the
[__] do I know what's going down on the
South Pole I mean
like I said whenever somebody saying
some wow [__] to me I need I start
asking them what other [__] do you
believe so I can know how believable you
are because if you believe because you
might be one of those people that just
believes [__] easily
hey everybody says give us give us some
volume
and every single door in the facility I
had complete access to every compartment
they manufactured what are you blowing
the whistle on that there are
Technologies at the South Pole station
that people can't even consider that
exist on this planet directed energy
weapon systems is something that people
need to get in their vocabulary fast the
Ice Cube neutrino detector is not simply
a passive listening device as presented
for the science that they're claiming it
to do it also has the capacity to
transmit there are embedded in the ice
what are called digital optical modules
Doms they're about the size of a
basketball the array embedded in the ice
is one kilometer by one kilometer by one
kilometer it is the world's largest
telescope and now because we have proven
that it can transmit it's the world's
largest directed energy weapon system it
is responsible for the earthquakes in
Christchurch New Zealand I physically
okay when he says one kilometer by one
kilometer by one kilometer does it mean
it's one kilometer high it's one
kilometer long and one kilometer wide I
think yeah a whole kilometer into the
ground yeah he could have just hit a
cube kilometer well it can it kind of I
mean it's more impressive I guess just
to think about it goes a kilometer into
the ground he's a former firefighter
contractor for Raytheon expose the
company's alleged ability to create
earthquakes worldwide linking to Hidden
directed energy weapon systems at South
Pole station
so what is this how would being a fi how
would a firefighter contractor have
access to that
I don't know how any of this is real I
have no idea I don't know what his job
was what's his name Eric Hecker yeah I
was trying to look him up I don't know
man he had some nice patches on his
jacket though Luke deficient yeah yeah I
mean you full of [__] until I see some
proof you you know because you know
extraordinary claims like require
extraordinary evidence it's like you
saying some wow [__] you gotta at least
show me something yes good point yeah
you was because you were a firefighter
contractor I don't feel like you would
have the keys to the secret death ray
you know well I think what he was saying
was that he was reading the documents of
the owner's manual
and that's when he realized that it's
capable of transmitting I believe he
says that in the show yeah but how again
how would a firefighter have access to
manuals and [__] I don't know yeah
that's crazy and why he's still alive
this is what the thing he's talking
about is when I Google it Antarctic muon
and neutrino detector array is what it's
called
and it goes let me see what it looks
like look the neutrino detector is real
right but that's so that's what the
facility on top of it and whoa look what
happens under the ground yeah holy [__]
but the reason it has to be so deep
under the ground is is
is so it's protected from
so it's protected from like solar from
like extra [__] so they know when when
it gets hit that it was a neutrino uh
you know right so it's it's it's real
like a lot of the stuff he said it was
real but here's the thing we also know
Joe is that the best place to hide a
lies between two truths the best
[__] is be they say a lot of true
[__] and they yeah and they sneak the
[__] in there right just like oh
yeah the neutrino detector is this and
this this and this that yeah and did you
know it can make you it can make you gay
Antarctic move on a new treated detector
array The Shield provided by looking for
only upward going neutrinos that must
have passed through Earth
something no other known particle can do
oh wow so it's through earth right
neutrinos neutrinos don't interact with
matter
almost at all
so that so that neutrino detector is way
way way way down and they're waiting to
see like Sparks of light so they know
that was a neutrino wow
um but if it's but if they put it on if
they put it on the surface I think they
can't tell the difference between one
that came because they're pouring out of
the sun right so they're looking for
ones that that have passed through the
Earth that have come from other places
wow so they know they know for sure so
every now and then it's it's so unlikely
that one will interact with matter that
like it doesn't happen that often
you know isn't it crazy that they spent
that much money to build that thing to
find that out yeah so so and also so
that's the other thing the thing this
guy is saying I don't even understand
how that would work how could it be both
things right how could it be a detector
and also a transfer yeah okay yeah
because I think it's just a pool full of
some special kind of water or some
special kind of liquid
that you know that it's a it's enough
where and it makes a neutrino more
likely to [__] hit
a nucleus or something but so I don't
understand how that could how that's
Gathering Power that it can transmit I
don't you know I don't I don't know
the thing about people like that and I'm
not saying this guy's not telling the
truth but I'm saying when I see stories
about like someone talking about like
some alien base that's underground and
there's just aliens down there and one
of them shot at me with a laser beam
if you were hiding some [__] like one of
the best ways to make it seem ridiculous
that you're hiding some [__] is get some
guys out of his [__] mind to go tell
some wacky ass story oh yeah feeling
full of lies tell them yeah you know we
started the earthquake in Christchurch
New Zealand it was started with this
thing and then and then you tell him
yeah it's actually a transmitter and you
have the guy go down and now everybody's
like oh
if that's kooky the idea of doing that
is Cookie directed energy weapon as
kooky when Memaw it wasn't even that
they got a real one somewhere so now
they've discredited the whole idea of
directed energy weapons and they got
some [__] out in the desert in Nevada
that's real the government loves
conspiracy I mean why wouldn't they if I
was
if I was running some top secret program
like a directed energy weapon I would
have someone
give them bad information give them fake
stories and then have them go expose it
like have someone who's like most likely
to blab and then have that person give
them this knucklehead story and then he
goes out and says it and then everybody
researches it you just tell Roseanne
it's terrible
tell Roseanne of the secret tell her
right before she goes on stage there's a
direct energy weapon yeah it's um
you know it's one of those things man
it's like I don't have no [__] idea
what they're capable of doing see that
right there that's the rare fact of me
this website it's a little red flaggy a
self-educated research investigator [__]
out of there that's worse than
homeschooling
that takes from as many Odd Life
Experiences and connects with others
Eric was raised on Long Island okay
yeah
proud of part of the Stargate project
run by the CIA and the DIA the child
what his childhood included being part
of the Stargate project run by the CIA
Dia later on it experiences in the
submarine service following that it
became a plumber for some of the
wealthiest people in the world back on
Long Island what
it's a weird turn of events in 2010 Eric
took a contract to work at the South
Pole station for a year
oh so he took it he went from being an
amazing plumber
to being a firefighter in in the South
Pole that's what he's saying okay always
the Avid researcher it was not until
Eric began working remotely throughout
the state of Alaska they started making
connections that his own life may not
have been what he thought it was now
he's trying to help others see that
things may not be as we were told three
exclamation points
yeah see this is and see this is the
thing man that feels a little red flaggy
does it yeah that feels real word and
then I mean what the [__] is that you
can donate support on patreon and shop
at CBD products
yeah yeah well the thing is it's like
babies telling the truth Maybe
but it's like would you trust a
self-educated doctor but if I wanted to
obscure the truth I would tell I would
tell everything to a wacky dude yeah man
see that's what that's what's going to
kill us it's the death of Truth we can
we can't tell what's true look maybe
that guy's honest maybe he's telling the
absolute truth and maybe it's so crazy
that we think that he's a loon because
the story sounds impossible story sounds
impossible that they would hide some
sort of a directed energy weapon in some
beautiful project to try to detect
neutrinos
right you would think that that would be
a really good way yeah but but at the
same time could they both could they do
both things we're too stupid why would
you try why would you have to hide
anything in the South Pole I mean ain't
nobody going everybody's looking because
that's a good place to do it